Sights, sounds, and music
are important components
of our everyday lives.
And even more so for the Android
ecosystem and the apps therein.
My name is Lajos from the
Android Video Framework Team.
I'm going to talk about how
to create great multimedia
experiences in Android
using some of our newer APIs
with a focus on video.
The good news is, you don't
have to be a [INAUDIBLE]
to add impressive multimedia
to your application
because Android does the
heavy lifting for you.
Android has easy to use,
high level APIs that
allow you to do some of
the most common media
tasks with minimal effort.
Namely, to play
and record video,
and also to take advantage
of external displays.
Let's discuss video playback.
Are you ready for
some good news?
Stop the presses.
In the L Developer Preview,
we have dramatically
improved the quality
of video playback
when using the high level APIs
for the most common video frame
rates.
OK, then.
The simplest way to play back
a video is using intents.
The benefit is that it uses the
user's preferred media player.
On the other hand,
this means that you
will have no control of
the playback experience.
Therefore, use this approach if
the media playback experience
is not an essential part
of your application.
When using intents
to play media,
always set the media type--
as illustrated in this code
sample-- so that the system
can select the best media
player for your content.
The next simplest way
to play back video
is using the system player.
MediaPlayer has been around
since the very first Android
release and it is
the easiest way
to add videos to
your application.
And it allows some
level of control,
such as pause and
seek, as well as
selecting the output surface.
MediaPlayer has
extensive documentation.
Check out the API reference
and don't miss the API guide
for advice on some common
tasks and headaches.
MediaPlayer can be
used for local files
as well as to play stream
media from the network.
Supported files include 3GP,
MP4, and WebM files over RTSP
and HTTP streaming.
MediaPlayer also supports
adaptive video playback
using HLS, HTTP Live Streaming.
For more information on
the supported data sources
and media formats, click
on the link on the screen.
Now let's dive into how,
or more appropriately,
where to display a video.
MediaPlayer displays video on
a surface, which can either
be the surface of a
SurfaceView or a GL texture.
Ice Cream Sandwich also added
support for TextureView.
A word of advice.
Surfaces may change or
be deleted dynamically,
so it is a recommended to
implement a Surface Holder
Listener.
This is how you display
video on a SurfaceView.
The main advantage of
using the SurfaceView
is that it is the only way
to display protected content.
However, since it is a window,
not technically a view,
it cannot be animated
like other views.
Here, the example is
updated to use TextureView.
TextureView, introduced
in API Level 14,
is similar to a SurfaceView
except that it uses GL textures
and it is truly a view.
And as such, it can be animated.
You can also use a texture
output of the media player
in a GL composition
and display that
in a GLSurfaceView
or a TextureView.
This is how you
configure MediaPlayer
to use a Surface Texture.
One of the latest
additions to MediaPlayer
is the ability to
display subtitles.
It was introduced in KitKat.
And you need to use
a VideoView for this.
A VideoView is basically a
SurfaceView with a dedicated
MediaPlayer object plus the
ability to display subtitles.
Android KitKat added support
for WebVTT subtitles.
However, some WebVTT features
are not supported at this time.
Use MediaPlayer getTrackInfo
to list the available subtitle
tracks.
If playing an HTTP live
stream, the WebVTT subtitle
tracks within are automatically
included in the media track
list.
You can also add subtitle
tracks using VideoView's Add
Subtitle Source Method,
as illustrated here.
You can monitor the success
of adding a subtitle track
using MediaPlayer's
OnInfoListener.
If the subtitle track has
been added successfully,
yay, a new track
has been created
and onInfo is called
with metadata update.
On the other hand,
if an error occurred
onInfo is called with either
an unsupported subtitle
or a subtitle timed out message.
You cannot programmatically
enable or disable subtitles.
This can only be done using
the System Preferences which
you can bring up using
this highlighted intent.
There can be at most one
selected subtitle track
at a time on a single VideoView.
By default, the first track
that best matches the System
Preferences is selected.
This can be none if
no track matches.
If the preferences change,
the default track selection
is automatically repeated.
Each subtitle has
four attributes
that are relevant
for track selection.
The first three, forced,
default, and autoselect,
are yes/no flags that are
commonly used for subtitles.
The last, and also arguably
least important attribute,
is its language.
The default track
selection is quite complex.
Each track is weighed
by several factors.
If captioning is enabled,
first and foremost,
we prefer tracks not
marked as forced.
Then, we prefer tracks
marked as default.
But this vector is only used
if the captioning language
is set to default.
Third, we prefer tracks marked
for autoselect, which we assume
to be okays, unless
marked otherwise.
Lastly, we favor tracks that
match the selected captioning
language.
A track must have at least
one of these flags set
or match the explicitly
selected captioning language
to qualify it.
If captions are off, only
forced tracks are considered.
But the rest of the
priorities remain.
An application can also use
MediaPlayer's select track
and deselect track to
programmatically set
the subtitle track.
Once this is done, however,
changes in the System
Preferences will have no effect
on the selected subtitle track
until the VideoView is reset.
You are on your own.
But all is not lost.
You can and should register
for CaptioningChangeListener
callback, as illustrated here,
so that you can be notified
if the captioning has been
turned on, turned off,
or if the locale has changed.
The other two callbacks,
font and style change,
are already handled for you
by the subtitle renderer.
Now let's talk about
recording video.
The simplest way to capture
video, you guessed it,
is using intents, which launches
the user's preferred camera
application to record a
video file from the camera.
There is very limited ability to
supply configuration parameters
for the capture video.
As such, the quality
of the resulting video
will strongly depend on the
user's device and preferred
camera application.
Therefore, this
approach is recommended
if the quality of
the video recording
is not essential for your task.
You can find more details on how
to use intents to capture video
at this link.
The preferred way to easily
capture or record video
into a local file is using
the system MediaRecorder.
MediaRecorder has been around
the whole life of Android.
And it allows some
level of control
over the video-- yay-- such
as its resolution and format.
I'm not going to say
too much about it,
as there is a great developer
guide available for you
for using the MediaRecorder
to capture video.
Check it out.
And use MediaRecorder.
Just one thing.
In the L Developer
Preview, the added
support to record
video from the Surface.
Ta da.
I can just see the clouds part
and the sun shine through.
Talking about things
that are heating up,
it seems that
everybody is buzzing
about 2nd Screen experience.
Android has you covered here.
You can use the Google Cast
SDK to launch content on a cast
receiver device,
such as a Chromecast.
The Cast sender API is
supported for all Android 2.3
or later devices.
As of KitKat MR1, you can
also mirror your screen
onto Google Cast receivers.
Use the presentation
class for this purpose.
A presentation is a
special kind of dialogue
whose purpose is to
show specific content
on a secondary display.
There are great API
guides and references
for the media router and
presentation classes.
There are also two fantastic
second screen sample apps
in the Android SDK
that use the display
manager or the MediaRouter
to detect additional screens.
Be sure to check them out.
That concludes this episode on
building great media experience
on Android.
Now go out and experiment with
the high level media APIs.
For more information, as always,
visit the Android developer
website for API reference,
guides, and sample
applications.
Thank you for your time.